日本に住んだことがないけど日本で英語を教えたいという外国人がたくさんいる
彼らの多くは大学を卒業したあとで実際に日本に来て
英語の先生になるそしてに3年したらまた自分の国に帰ってしまう
今日はこの現象について話したいと思う日本に住んだことがないけど
日本で英語をし
自衛隊まずこの表現を分析してみよう
英語圏以外の国であれば英語の先生になるのはそれほど難しいことではないこの理屈
から考えると日本に住んで英語を教えたいって言うような人たちは日本にこだわって
いることがわかる
アニメが好きだったり格闘技が好きだったり
日本女性
が好きだったりしてとにかく彼らは日本のドッカーが好きなはずだ
しかもそれは自分の家族と友達を捨てて生まれ育った場所から離れてもいいぐらい強い
情熱である
簡潔に言うと日本に住んだことがないけど日本で英語を教えたいというような人は多く
が
日本びいきであるまあ多くがそうだ
アートオンラインの他下って行ったほうが正確だろうけど
ただしここで申し上げたいのは彼らが日本 b 気になるのは日本に来る前である
かなりの想像力が働いているわけだ秋葉原のパソコン探しや恋人とのお台場デートなど
日本に引っ越す前はこのような楽しい思いを創造する
想像して欠点がない日本頭の中で膨らませるのだ
メイド喫茶のオムライスからもらった食中毒や横浜
までの恋人喧嘩などは想像しない川崎駅から歩いて15分もかかるのに
月9万円もするせま8パートでのゴキブリ戦争は誰も想像しない
だからいわゆる日本贔屓は実際に日本に来たらガッカリして自分の国にやがて変えて
しまうと多くの人が有力
僕はこれは実は違うと思うエッセイ用のコスプレしか考えていない
アニメ用パクは確かにゴキブリ戦争は予想しないが減っ西洋のコスプレしか考えてい
ない
アニメオタクは充実した健康保険制度も安くて美味しいほっともっともそう
想像しないつまり予期せぬ失望はもちろんあるが予期せぬ感動もある10回も行ったら
原宿コスプレの新センサーが多少擦れるかもしれないが急に悪いことばかりが起こる
わけではない
だったらなぜみんな自分の国に変えてしまうのか
個人的な意見だが答えは英語を cl にあると思う
日本匹達の夢は日本に住むことであり英語を教えることではないはずだ
しかしどうしても日本に住みたい人にとっては仕事を犠牲にするのは難しい選択では
ない
日本に住めるなら喜んで英語を教えると彼らが信じるわけだ
残念ながらみんな sa 様のお宅であり英語の文法オタクではない
だからそれを3年間毎日9時から5時まで教えていたらさすがのアニメオタクも疲れて
くる
考え方が悲観的になり
客観的に見て安くて美味しいホットもとさえもやがて
嫌いな日本へと変化してしまうそう
彼らは日本ではなく日本で送っている自分の生活が嫌いになってしまう
なにしろ彼らの本当の夢は日本を楽しむことであり給料が低い英語の先生になるか
とではないということでここで日本で英語を教えたいという視聴者たちに一つ上限し
たいと思う
日本に来たことかなければ初めて来日した時は大きく感動するだろう
しかし生活をしていると日本が目標から自分が住んでいる国にか
終わっていくその時に大事になってくるのは毎日の9時から5時までの間であるあなた
は趣味が英語の音声学の本を読むことでバンコクでもいいからとにかく英語を教えたい
と思うなら長く気持ちよく日本で英語を教えることができるだろうし過疎などの趣味が
コスプレイをして写真を撮ることであればあなたは英語の先生でをなく
コスプレーモデルになるべきだそのため写真手の作り方やポーズの取り方など
モデルに必要な知識と能力を身につけるべきだ
日本に住んだことがないけど日本で英語を教えたい
いう人たちにとあなたは一生来日することができなかったらどのような仕事を目指す
その仕事こそ日本ですべきだ
そしてそれが実現できるように今から必要な資格などを取得すべきだ
でないといくらキリトも加工をするのが好きだとしてもそれを毎日自分が楽しめるもの
によっ
できないそれどころかずっと同じセリフを繰り返してしまう
英会話オンラインの mpc になってしまうだけだ
ni